The finale of the
second series of Outer Banks
comes with
a whole load of twists,
as you've come to expect
from
this adventure mystery show
starring our favourite
runaway pogues.
We got it!
So much happened
this season.
John B went from fugitive
to prisoner
to exonerated man.
Oh, you know
they can't keep me in, boy!
Pope found out
his family heirloom is
a giant golden cross.
We did it!
And Kiara got kicked out
by her parents.
Go live
like a fricking pogue!
But let's get to some
of the twists and turns
of the final few episodes
and dig into
what they reveal
and what they set up for
the pogues in the future.
Let's start with the first.
Mid-season,
Ward Cameron appears to die
aboard his ship
after setting off
an explosion
and admitting to
all of his misdeeds.
I did it.
I did all of it.
Crucially,
he also takes the fall
for shooting the sheriff.
Of course, as Sarah
and John B witnessed,
it was actually Rafe
who murdered her.
Not the first
or the last time
he tries to murder someone
on this show,
yet only the pogues seem to
see him
as what he really is.
-We know what you did!
-Hey.
-Murderer!
-No.
Speaking of things not being
what they seem,
there was definitely
something fishy
about Mr. Cameron's death.
And it turns out
he faked his death
in a bid to escape
and to ensure Rafe
didn't see prison time.
It's the only way to be
a family again.
He ends the series
still very much alive,
despite a run-in
with John B.
While John B seemed to
have the chance
to end the war between them
once and for all,
with eerie mirroring of how
Ward dealt with his father,
more on that later,
he decides to
take the higher ground
and spare
Mr. Cameron's life.
So, now we wonder:
will Ward Cameron's bid
for freedom at sea work
or will the cops realise
he's still alive?
Now, last season,
the drama all hinged
on the treasure
aboard the Royal Merchant.
With that treasure found…
and lost,
there's a gap for a new hunt
on the horizon.
When Pope gets a strange
letter from a rich lady
demanding to know
the location of a key,
a new mystery is afoot.
And it turns out Pope's
family was more involved
with the Royal Merchant than
any of them ever realised.
Here lies Denmark Tanny:
the famous ex-slave.
Denmark and Cecilia
Are your great grandfolks
going way back.
They eventually find
Denmark Tanny's cross
in a dilapidated church.
Unfortunately, after Pope
goes into anaphylactic shock
due to wasp stings,
forcing them to abandon the
treasure for medical help,
so does Rafe Cameron.
He, in turn, brings it
aboard the ship
carrying our old friend
Ward Cameron.
At this point,
the final battle
upon the coastal venture
is not just one
for the cross,
but for Pope's heritage.
The time
where people do shit to us
and we just sit back
and take it is over!
That's my boy!
Thanks to help
from their old friend Cleo,
they get so close
to their goal.
At one point, Pope
is willing to let the cross
drop into the ocean
rather than
let the Camerons have it.
If we can't have it,
no one can.
Sorry, Denmark.
Unfortunately,
Rafe and the crew manage to
drag it back aboard
while Pope
and his friends watch
from
their departing speedboat.
It's safe to say, however,
the search for the cross
transformed Pope,
so it's not likely
he'll let them take it
without a fight
to get it back.
This shit ain't over.
The pogues, along with
adoptees Cleo and Sarah,
end up on a seemingly
abandoned island
somewhere in the Caribbean
and decide to stay put to
live their best pogue life.
I claim thee Poguelandia.
I like the ring of it.
I'm going to make a flag.
It's going to have a chicken
on it.
With a coconut bra,
smoking a J.
And crocs.
Back on the outer banks,
their family and friends
have reported them missing,
so exactly how much trouble
are they going to be in
upon their return?
There's one final mystery
unveiled in the finale.
Limbrey, the rich woman
obsessed with
finding Denmark's cross,
knocks on a stranger's door.
And that stranger?
Well, it's only Big John,
a.k.a. John B's dad.
He seems to have been there
for a while
from the conversation
Limbrey has
with his caretaker.
How is he?
Half dead.
For a long time.
Just like John B found
plenty of notes
about the Royal Merchant
in his father's
abandoned office
in season one,
Limbrey takes a peek
around his makeshift office
in this new home
with coordinates written
everywhere in red ink.
Unsurprisingly, Limbrey is
there about the shroud
she believed to be hidden
in Denmark's cross
and Big John seems to
know all about it,
but his information
comes at a cost.
I know where it is.
I can help you.
But you…
have to help my son.
This cliff hanger leaves us
with so many questions,
namely:
How did Big John survive?
Who rescued him?
Is John B going to
find out about this?
And how is he going to feel
about it?
And how will Pope feel
about this unlikely team
comprising of his friend's
supposedly deceased father
and a woman
who tried to kill him
for his family's treasure?
Well, if news
of a season three drops,
you'll know
where to find us.
Until then…
Welcome back
to the pogue life.
Full pogue.
Full pogue!